il ya 30 ans exactement au cap en
afrique du sud un professeur inconnus
alors christian barnard effectué la
première greffe du coeur trente ans plus
tard elle est technique n'ont cessé
d'évoluer aujourd'hui on envisage même
la greffe de coeur d'animaux sur l'homme
françoise vallin
c'est ce chirurgien d'afrique du sud qui
a osé tenter l'opération
en quelques heures la nouvelle se répand
dans le monde entier
le greffé un homme de 53 ans ne survivra
que 18 jours
mais christian barnard récidive et
d'autres équipes se lancent dans la
transplantation cardiaque à paris lé
professeur cabrol puis du boss et
cachera temple opération pour tous les
cardiaques le symbole d'espoir reste
emmanuel vitryat un marseillais greffé
en 68 il est sûr vais plus 18 ans avec
le coeur d'un autre
auguste de l'homme lui fêtera bientôt
ses dix ans de greffe et ne cesse de
dire merci aux donneurs en juin dernier
il lui rend hommage en faisant
l'ascension du mont blanc avec d'autres
transplantés arriver là haut tout le
monde n'a pas pu s'empêcher de penser
aux donneurs et elle ce coeur qui
battait à notre poitrine vraiment elle
était à l'unisson du donc nous avait été
fait aujourd'hui la greffe cardiaque est
une opération presque banal mais
malheureusement de plus en plus rares
elle souffre surtout actuellement d'un
manque de donneurs d'organes qui est
vraiment dramatique alors les chercheurs
s'oriente désormais vers les organes
d'animaux c'est ce que l'on appelle la
xénogreffe la technique est au point
mais les médecins veulent des garanties
pour leurs malades
c'est un problème essentiellement parce
thériault logique et virologiques pour
ne pas transmettre et des maladies
infectieuses des animaux père l'homme
avec une possibilité de propagation
qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui ch est
malgré tout les chirurgiens croit les
premières opérations devraient avoir
lieu d'ici cinq ans